Emergence is to me one of the most exciting
things that we can study in science.
When patterns spontaneously form in systems
comprised of objects whether they're atoms
or molecules or nanoparticles or flocks of
birds, those patterns are said to be emergent
because they're not evident by simply looking
at the individual constituents of the system.
For example, when you look up in the sky and
see these intricate patterns that birds form
when they're flying around, those patterns
are nothing that you would have guessed at
if you just looked at the birds and thought
about how the birds are flying next to one
another.
If you take water and you freeze it into ice
in the freezer or you make a solution of nanoparticles
and out comes a complicated photonic structure,
you would never have guessed just by looking
at individual water molecules or individual
nanoparticles what those structures would look like.
Emergence underlies so many different types
of questions in science — from the kinds
of traffic jams that you get from the interactions
of many cars on the roads, to even the origin
of life and how complex structures emerged
from simpler structures.
In my group, we study emergence by making
mathematical models of different kinds of
systems, and then we solve these models using
computers, usually very large, very fast computers,
and what's important about using the computer
is that we're able to strip away one-by-one,
all the kinds of interactions that might be
present in a system so that we can see the
role of all of the different interactions.
One of the contributions to emergence that
my students and I are particularly fascinated
by is the idea of entropy.
Entropy is typically thought of as disorder.
The idea that entropy can actually contribute
to order is sometime surprising to people,
but in fact entropy can be the cause of emergence
in many different systems.
That is something that's really interesting
to us.